Adam is with us in Indianapolis hi Adam
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show good to
hear from you
you too sir how can I help hey you know
about a yeah I said a quick question I
am basically maxed out on my 401k
contributions for the year not yet but I
will be and I've got some student loans
that I've been working on paying off
since the beginning of the year in
addition to my falling cabin investing
in a lot of physical gold and silver
that I have and I was wondering if I
should stop that and focus solely on
student loans or should I continue to
give both and kind of you know split
between the two I would stop investing
in gold or silver period I don't put
money in precious metals at all they
have a lousy long term track record
horrible and you know look it up fifteen
or twenty year track record on them the
rates of return are horrendous so now I
would catch every bit of that out and
put it on your student loans
can you pay your student loans off if
you do that today okay so what is your
household income I make about 240 here
good for you how much student loan debt
have you got sixty playlists okay and so
you have thirty thousand dollars in
metal and you have no cash except your
401k other than that I've got about ten
thousand in cash - okay all right I'm
gonna throw that at it down to a
thousand and I'm gonna temporarily stop
your 401k until you get this student
loan debt done and then I'll restart it
you know what I wouldn't either not
making 240 you're gonna pay that you're
gonna have 15,000 left so no I mean are
twenty thousand left I'm gonna pay that
off very very fast making 240 I want
should be out of debt though like by
September okay okay I mean everything
know everything go and dump everything
out of your budget and don't do anything
you get these student loans cleared up
like the house is on the fire and then
get that in your rear view mirror then
let's put your emergency fund in place
in cash at three to six months of
expenses start putting fifteen percent
of your income away into 401ks which you
and not do quite you're not quite in
like a raw a Roth after that maybe you
could do a backdoor Roth is all you can
do
possibly are you doing Roth 401 case no
a just a straight-up employer for a long
k they don't have a Roth version they
don't okay you may or may not be
eligible depending on how much is in
that and what you've done therefore a
backdoor Roth you got to look at that
with your investment professional sit
with your smart Wester Pro and figure
that out yeah we want you to start
putting are you do you have a home okay
then let's just start I want to put
fifteen percent of our income away on
retirement start kids college and then
attack the home that's our baby steps
baby steps
one's a thousand dollars twos debt-free
but the house three is a fully funded
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses this is the order then four is
fifteen percent of your income into
retirement five is kids college six is
pay off your house early and Jared I
will tell you this with your income you
should be a millionaire very very
quickly doing that steps all of the data
that we have studying millionaires and
we've just completed a study of ten
thousand one hundred and fifty
millionaires that is the most detailed
study ever done on millionaires and in
the largest study by far two of the data
points that we found with almost every
millionaire north of 80 percent of them
pay off their homes avoid debt of any
kind ever and invest in their 401 K if
you do those three things with your
income you're going to be a millionaire
in probably six or seven years if not
sooner you are well on your way to very
well done and congratulations on doing
so well very proud of you excellent
excellent work